[Müzik]
bir arkeolog hocaya sorulacak en
Pragmatik soru Sanırım bu Nerede bu
hazinenin yeri
yaklaşık 23 yıldır 2000 yılında başladım
Anadolu'nun dağlarında ovalarında birçok
kazı ve yüzey araştırması yaptım en çok
duyduğum soru bu hocam Nerede bu
hazinenin yeri
defineciden köylüsüne
milletvekilinden başkanına ailem de
dahil
dayıların filan hazine peşinde arkeolog
yeğenim var
dayıların da dahil olmak üzere her
kesimden bu soruyu duydum Nerede bu
hazinenin yeri
öyle hikayeler Duydum ki
bir kitap dahi yazabilirmi Hatta bu
kitabı çıkarsam ne olur bence çok
satanlar listesine bir girebilir 2 tane
kitap planım var komik olsun diye bir bu
defineci hikayeleri Bir de
öğrencilerin kağıtları öğrencilerin
sınav kağıtları o kadar komik şeyler var
ki
işte papaz büyüsü tutuyormuş Hazineyi
oradan oraya taşıyormuş kaçırıyormuş
papaz büyüsü
papaz bulup okutmak gerekiyormuş ki
papazı bulup ne okutacağız oku Bir
şeyler
yılanlar bekçisiymiş falan filan
yılanlar tutuyormuş Hazineyi Nerede bu
hazinenin yeri
yıllarca bu soruyu çok düşündüm
zihnime kadar işlet zihnimin içerisinde
Nerede bu hazinenin yeri dedim Merak
etmeyin konuşmanın sonunda hazinenin
yerini söyleyeceğim
Mesleğimi çok seviyorum
arkeolog olmak çocukluk hayalimdi
çok şükür bu yolun
yolcusu'yum hem de hem yolcusu oldum hem
de hocası oldum çok büyük bir şans benim
için Lakin öğrenmeye devam ediyorum
çünkü bu topraklar öğretmeyi hiç
bırakmıyor Ben profesyonel bir
öğrenciyim o Çenet de olsam Profesör de
olsam hayat boyu öğrencisi olmaya bu
yolun
suyun yorulmak bilmediği gibi biz de
mektebimiz Anadolu'nun dağlarında
ovalarında Sarp kayalıklarında
yorulmadan çalıştık değerli dostlar çok
çalıştık inanın çok çalıştık zordur
arkeoloji
bizim burada olmamız da sizlerin
huzuruna çıkmamızda tedx konuşmacısı
olmamızda İşte bu mesleğimizin nedeniyle
oldu Anadolu'nun bizlere vermiş olduğu
dersler nedeniyle ben buradayım
mektebemiz Aslında Anadolu coğrafyası
tarihi ve kültürel zenginlikleridir
ne zor değil mi Sırların perdesini
aralamak bizim mesleğimiz Sırların
perdesini aramak yıllardır yapbozun
parçalarını birleştirmekle zamanımız
geçti
küçücük bir buluntu inanın küçücük bir
buluntu Koskoca tarihi değiştirdi bunu
gözlerimle şahit oldum
O yüzden küçük diye atlanmadan yapbozun
parçalarını sürekli arıyoruz
geçmişin bilinmezliğiyle geleceğin
dünyasının bilinmezliği birleşince
önümüze aydınlatmak için muhtaç
olduğumuz en önemli kavram
bilimsel doğru bilgidir
O yüzden hazinenin yerine bilimsel
bilgiyle ulaşacağız
Ancak ben bu hazinenin yerini anlamak ve
bilimsel bilgiye daha iyi Vakıf
olabilmek için bu yola bir şey ekledim
sanat
2000 yılında arkeolojik kazı
çalışmalarına başladığım dönemde
belgelemek için elime aldığım Fotoğraf
makinesini Anadolu'nun değerlerine yani
insanına çevirdim
ahmetsin Zeynep amcanın Zeynep teyzenin
Ahmet amcanın öyküsünü iki boyutlu bir
kadraja sıkıştırmaya çalıştım Yani insan
hikayelerine fotoğraflamaya başladım
2000'li yılların başında fotoğrafçılığın
yayıldığını hepimiz biliyoruz aynı
dönemde Anadolu fotoğrafçıların da
toplandı etrafımızda birden
binlerce insan etrafımıza Toplandı ve
Anadolu fotoğrafçılığı kavramı oluştu
nasıl
edebiyatta yeni yeni
yenilikçiler vardır yeni akımcılar
vardır Biz de Anadolu'nun fotoğrafçılığı
kavramı akımı oluşturduk ve tezlere
makalelere konu olduk biliyor musunuz
öyle sürprizlerle dolu ne mutlu ki bana
bu akımın ve bu kavramın kurucularından
biri oldum
şimdiki hedefimiz ise Anadolu'da
kurduğumuz bu birliğin Bu güzelliğin bir
benzerini Gönül coğrafyamızda başarmak
hedefimiz de Türk fotoğrafçılar
birliğini kurup kültürel değerlerimizi
fotoğraf sanatıyla gelecek aktarmak
sanatı ülkemiz için bir yumuşak güç
haline getirmek istiyoruz yumuşak güç
top Power sanatın kültürel anlamda bir
güç olduğunu onlarca kere tecrübe ettim
2018 senesinde Yörükler diyarı
Silifke'nin dağlarında
arkeolojik bir yüzey araştırması
sırasında bir köylünün mütevazı bir
fırında
dükkanında Çektiğim bu Kare bir kareyle
belki de kariyerimin en büyük hazinesi
oldu
40-45 derecelik kavurucu bir sıcakta
öğlen molası için arkeolojik arkeoloji
ekibimizde yemek yerken Fırının içinde
oynaşan iki kardeşi gördüm
öyle güzel öyle neşeli oynuyorlardı ki o
anı saf duygularını
dakikalarca izledim değerli dostlar
bu anlar çocukluğumu aklıma getirmişti
abimle olan muhabbetim gözümün önüne
geliyor geçmişe dönemeyecek olmanın
hüznünü yaşıyordu
sonra dayanamadım o zamanlar bir uzvum
gibiydi bir silah gibi hemen çektim
fotoğraf makinemi aldım çocukların
yanına gittim mis gibi kokan fırını
düşünebiliyor musunuz o kokuyu hissedin
o fırının içinden çıkmış ekmek kokuları
arasında çocuklardan büyük olana sordum
Sen kardeşini çok mu seviyorsun dedim
utangaç bir tavırla konuşmadı kardeşine
öpücüğü kondurdu o an nasip oldu ve ben
de bir deklanşöre bastım
sonuca bile bakmadım biliyor musunuz
fotoğraf makinesine çıkarsa bahtıma
dedim isimlerini sordum
çok büyük sürpriz Halil ve İbrahim
dediler Bu çocukların ismi Halil ve
İbrahim O an hikaye kafamda bir bütün
hale gelmişti Halil ve İbrahim
kardeşliğinin birliğinin fotoğrafını
çekmiştim
yorucu bir arkeolojik kazı günün sonunda
fotoğrafları kaydederken büyük bir
heyecanla elim ayağım titreyerek
çektiğin o akşam fotoğrafa baktım ve bu
sonuçla karşılaştım
biliyor musunuz çok önemlidir
fotoğrafçılar Arasında ilk ben tebessüm
ettim bu fotoğrafı ilk içimde aynı şu
anda ilk sizin de karşılaştığınız gibi
ben tebessüm ettim ilk daha sonra
Milyonlarca kişi tebessüm etti yorucu
bir arkeolojik kazı ilk tebessüm ettim
ve
daha sonra köyüne doktoraya gittim işte
o zamanlarda Köln'de doktora yapıyordum
ve doktor eğitim için Köln'e döndüm
Avrupa Birliği'nin açmış olduğu fotoğraf
yarışmasında bu fotoğraf ile katıldım
yarışmayı Avrupa parlamentosu
düzenliyordu hem jürinin seçimleri hem
de
halk oylaması olacaktı
oylama sonunda
101 bin oy aldım bu hani şu an gündemde
ya imza topluyorlar Ben de 101 bin Oya
aldım düşünün aradaki farkı İkincide
2000 küsür 2300 küsür oy aldı 101 bin
2300 küsür bir de üstüne
oy aldım Bir de üstüne jürinin seçiminde
de birinci olduğumu fark ettim
söylediler Hem bir jürinin seçimde hem
de halk oylamasında birinci oldum ilk
arayan kim oldu Köln Üniversitesi
Rektörü oldu
beni öğlen yemeğine davet etti Körün
Belediye Başkanı aynı şekilde beni
ağırladı ABD'nin birçok Bakanı yetkilisi
aradı Avrupa Birliği'nin
ailemin manevi desteği haricinde kimse
maalesef beni ne aradı ülkemden ne de
sordu
Bir kişi bir daha aramadı üzüldün mü
Evet yaşımız genç 2010'lardan
bahsediyoruz üzüldün mü Evet ama
devletime küsmedim Ne de olsa evlat
babasına Küsmez
o an düşündüm kültürel faaliyetlerde bir
numara olacak bir Türkiye inşa etmemiz
gerektiğini o yaşta karar verdim Onun
için yetişecektim sonuna kadar da
ilerleyecektim
eleştirdiğimiz şeyleri değiştireceğimiz
makamlara gelmeyi hayal ettim Çok kritik
bir laf eleştirdiğim şeyleri değiştirmek
çünkü hep eleştiriyoruz ama o yol için
bir şey yapmıyoruz
sonra Madrid'de ödül törenine gittim
İspanya kralından ödül aldım
Brüksel'de VIP araçlarla transferim
sağlandı kırmızı halılar ile karşılandım
sevdiğim şarkıları önceler önceden
sormuşlardı Ben de niye sordular diye
merak etmiştim salona girer girmez Barış
Manço'nun Halil İbrahim sofrasını
çaldılar
5 dile çevrilen Halil İbrahim Sofrası
hikayesi ile orada Anadolu kardeşliğini
birliğini anlattık
bizleri
farklılıklarımızla bölmeye çalışan
Avrupa Birliği parlamentosu kalesine
sanat ile Gedik açtık bunu sanat ile
başarmıştım Ben kültürel diplomasinin ne
olduğunu bu iletişim dilini kitaplardan
değil onlarca kere yaşadığım örneklerle
öğrenmiştim
Üstüne bir de 2010 yılında Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti devlet fotoğraf yarışmasında
birincilik alarak büyük bir mutluluk
yaşadım Halil İbrahim bereketi hayatıma
yerleşmişti
öğrenci başıma Doktor öğrencisiyim çok
zor şartlar Doktor öğrencisi başıma ödül
kadar uçak bileti ödeyerek köyünden
Ankara'ya devletin ödül veriyor diye
koşa koşa gittim
Lakin Türkiye'nin bir numaralı ödülünün
sönük bir ödül töreniyle verilmesi benim
bu Demin de bahsettiğim kararımı
pekiştirmişti
yerel değerlerimizin gücü Dünyanın her
yerinde kabul görmekteydi bunu defalarca
yaşadım ülkemizin tarihi büyüklüğü ve
bakiyesi sayesinde sunmuş olduğu bu
kültürel gücü iliklerime kadar
hissetmiştim
ben bu gücü Türk olduğumuzu duyup
kimsenin giremediği yerlere bizi sokan
görevlilerin olduğu Kudüs'te uçak
krizinden sonraki ilk Türk etkinliği
olan tataristan'da Ben Anadolu
fotoğrafçısı olmak istiyorum diyen
kişilerin olduğu arnavutluktaki
etkinliklerimizde Türk fotoğrafçılar
birliğini anlattığımızda ağlayarak kurun
üye olalım diyen Makedon dostlarımızla
birçok örnekte gördüm ben bu gücü
Ben Dostlar Anadolu hazinelerini
kültürel Diplomasi anlayışı ile bilimsel
ya da sanatsal yolla anlatmaya baş
koydum
belki varılmaz
Hayat zaten varılan değil yürünen bir
yoldur Bu benim sözüm çok düşündüm bu
sözü Çünkü sürekli varmak istiyorum ama
varılmaz
köprünün üstüne ev yapılmaz
yapılmayacağını da çok iyi biliyorum bu
köprüden geçmez güzel orada kalması
değil bunu da biliyorum Lakin ne gelirse
başa yoldaştan gelir yoldaştan değil
yoldandır
bir gün bizim bu niyetimizi görecek
kişiler Elbette olacaktır bu zamana
kadar yüzden fazla ödül aldım hepsi
kişisel ödüllerdi Ben de Akın hocam gibi
yüzün üzerinde ödül aldım ulusal ya da
uluslararası herkes başarılarımıza
özendi Lakin bizim gibi kişiler kişisel
ödüllerden haz duymaz hale
gelebiliyorlar Ben toplumları değerleri
kültürel hazineleri
kapsayacak ve kalkındıracak ödüller
istiyorum Ne olursunuz Ben büyük Türk
devletinin kültürel açıdan yönetecek
makama gelmek istiyorum
benim için sanat amaçlarım için bir ayak
ise bilim de diğer ayağıdır
biri iletişim dili diğeri bilimsel bilgi
Salt bilgi olursa şu anki dünyada
anlatmakta zorluk çekeriz toplumla
buluşturamayız kendi camiamızda kalırız
ve bilimi insan için yaptığımızı
unuturuz bunu yapan çok bilim insanı var
inanın bilimi insan için yaptığının
farkına varmayan çok bilim insanı var
bilimi insan için yapıyoruz biz halkın
diline indirgemek insanın ayağına
götürmek stratejileri üretmek bizim
görevimiz Bilim insanlarının görevi
halkın insanların ayağına götürmektir
maalesef ülkemizde standartlık yapmak
bakın çok önemli bir şey söyleyeceğim
ülkemizde standardı yapmak görevini
yapmakla eşdeğer hale geldi
Hayır biz ne norveççiyiz ne almanyayız
Biz
standart üstü çalışmak zorundayız Biz
Gelişmekte olan bir Türkiye'yi ülkeyiz
O yüzden halkımıza insanımıza bilim
insanları olarak bilgi götürmek
zorundayız
Arkeologlar biliyorsunuz biraz
lümpen Elit kesim oluyor çok da
eleştiriliyoruz bunları söylediğimiz
için ama biz bilgiye götürmek zorundayız
Bu doğrultuda Ben Anadolu'nun
hazinelerini insanlığa yeni düzenine
uygun olarak aktarmak için dijital
arkeoloji Digital arkeolog
diye anabilim dalı kurmaya çalışıyorum
gözün iktidarı döneminde görselim ve
teknolojinin ön plana çıktığı geleceğin
teknik arkeologlarına yetiştirmek
istiyorum biri de geldi Daha da
yetiştiriyorum
Sağ olsunlar bu çabamı gören hocalarımız
beni dijital arkeoloji komisyonunun
başına getirdiler kıymetli hocalarımızla
planlar stratejiler yaptık arkeolojik ve
kültürel miras hazinelerimizi yani
Anadolu'nun değerlerini geçmişini
dünyaya daha iyi anlatmak için hazırız
ama sadece hazırız
Tabii bu yolda zorluklar yaşadık mı
o zorluklar ne zorluklar yaşadık başta
en yakınlarım danışmanım benim Doktor
and yani doktora Fatiha dediğimiz
danışmanım
konforunu bozacağımı düşünen büyük
başlar birçok kişi Siz bilim değil film
peşindesiniz dediler
bilimi daha görsel ve teknoloji halinde
anlatmak bilim dışı olarak görüldü
Bu arada Aramızda Kalsın filmde
peşindeyim
senaryoculara buradan film şeyleri de
film peşindeyiz Örneğin Türkistan'da
Türkistan coğrafyasında yapacağımız
arkeolojik kazılara film ekibimiz
teknolojimiz ve bilim diplomasimizle
gideceğiz
netflix'te sakkara vardır İzleyen var mı
Sakarya'nın sırları
işte orada izleyin nasıl Mısır
pazarlıyor kültürel diplomasını Biz de
pazarlayacağız pazarlık yapmadığınız şey
sizin değildir yani kültürel Diplomasi
ordumuzu kuracağız Biz çok yönlü yeni
nesil bilim insanıyız çok yönlülük bu
ülkede desteklenmeli
kesinlikle entelektüel insan
hazinelerimiz de Türkiye ilerler
entelektüel demek de iki şal iki Papyon
iki sakal değildir uzmanı olduğu bir
alanın dışında ilgi alanları
oluşturmaktır
Ankara'daki eski bölüm Başkanım Aramızda
Kalsın bir sürü sanatsal ödül aldığımda
yeni geldim Almanya'dan sanatsal ödül
almaya başladığımda Ya sen dedi Artist
misin bilim insanı mısın dedi
Evet dedim artistim Ben artist ne demek
sanatçı sanatla uğraşıyoruz Ben hem
bilim insanıyım hem artist Hani artist
deyince Artist misin Halbuki artistsin
beni küçümseyerek söyledi ama Evet
artistim Aramızda Kalsın bir de bunu
bana söylüyor Bölüm başkanımız 5 Özgün
bilimsel kitabı iki çeviri kitabı 3 katı
puanla doçentliğe başvurmuş bir hocayım
bilimsel tarafım da güçlüdür Ben şimdi
başlarmışım Kanuni Sultan Süleyman kim
Ben ki diye bazen kendinizi övmeniz
gerekiyor
Çünkü Aslanı kediye boğdurma Bu ülkenin
geleneklerinden bir tanesi
zamanında köşe başlarına tutmuş iki çay
iki çorba içip
desteklenmiş makamlarda son tüketim
tarihi geçmiş bir sürü insan var
bunlara karşı kendinize ezdirmeyin
başkaları sizin içinizde hazinenin
farkına varmayabilirler
umurunuzda olmasın
doğru olduğuna inandığınız bir yol ise
denemeden yenilmeden vazgeçmeyin
Deneye deneye Yenile Yenile doğruyu
bulursunuz
başkası yenmesin sizi siz yenileyin
Almanların bir kavramı var işte augment
bizdeki hacıyatmaz bilenler hemen
söyledi bizdeki hacıyatmaz gibi olmak
lazım Tokadı yediğin zaman Aynı hızla
dikenmek gerekir hayatta deriniz biraz
kalın olmalı Hayat yoksa hayat
duygusallar nekropolisidir
Türkler Maalesef çok hakim olduğu bu
coğrafyada Türklerin hakim olduğu bu
coğrafyada duygusallık ve akılcılığın
dengesini çok iyi kurmamız gerekiyor
üretenler ile planlayan beyin arasında
yüreğimiz olmalıdır
bu tip rehberler olmasaydı İnsanoğlu
vahşidir birbirini yerdi insanın içine
vicdanı eklemek doğal olarak korku
yüzlerce etmek gerekir Anadolu'da bir
laf vardır kor kanına nasıl ağlamazmış
bu arada Biz Türkler bir tek savaşırken
korkmayız Ne de olsa İstiklal Marşı'mızı
ilk kelimesi Korkma
Almanya'nın Marşı'nın kelimesi nedir
bilen var mı
Her şeyin üzerinde Almanya
Sonuç olarak dostlar
hazine Evet söylüyorum hazinenin yerini
yaşadığımız topraklardır
vatanımızdır her türlü zenginliği ile
her türlü problemi ile her türlü
sıkıntısıyla
Türkiye'dir en büyük hazine aklımızdır
büyük Atatürk'ün vizyonu olan aklın
yolunda yürümektir en büyük hazine
dilimizdir türkçedir
bizi iyi insan yapmaya çalışan
inancımızdır ama belki de en önemli
hazine aldığımız nefestir sağlığımızdır
ve bizlere Yaratanın lütfettiği
çocuklarımızdır hepinize teşekkür
ediyorum eyvallah
[Müzik]